I'm Daniel Arenberg and I work in tc39
and I came here to tell you about bigan
but first let's talk about numbers math
up pal is this function that can take a
number to particular power so here X
will be two to the 53rd power actually
now you can just write 2 to the starstar
53 so what is that equal this huge
number starting with a 9 and ending with
it too what do you get when you add 1 to
that so this 2 to the 53 plus 1 the same
number back this huge number starting
with a nine-inning with it - what what's
going on so in this talk I'll tell you
about why numbers do this how we can fix
this using big end and how tc39 has been
developing begin in partnership with the
JavaScript community how you can get
involved to shape the next version of
JavaScript I really want your help in
all of this we can't do it without you
so first about numbers numbers in
JavaScript are 64 bit floats
floating-point binary numbers so that's
basically like scientific notation
remember from grade school 30,000 you
could represent as 3 times 10 to the 5
and here the exponent would be 5 the
sign is positive 1 and the fraction is 3
and I Triple E 754 floating point
numbers are just like that except it's
base 2 instead of base 10 so we've the
sign which is one bit and we the
exponent which is 11 bits in the
fraction and 52 bits so our our friend
two to the 53rd power looks like this
when you put it in a in a floating point
it sign is 0 to represent positive 1 the
exponent is that that numbers starting
with a 1 and the the fraction is all
zeroes it has an implicit sort of one
point before the zeros the next biggest
number is actually that ending with a 4
if you look at the last digits the last
digit of this number ending in a 2 is 0
and the last digit of the one being 1 is
1 there's actually no numbers in between
when I say number I mean these binary
floating-point numbers ultimately if
we're representing something in 64 bits
there's only two to the 64 different bit
patterns so we can't represent every
single actual number that exists in the
world or every single integer even at
some point we have to round or go up to
infinity or have an error but this seems
like a pretty random edge case does this
ever actually come up in practice it
turns out it does so in Twitter's API
there's an ID field stuff like tweets
represented by JSON objects and the ID
that you get over the network might look
like this this big number ending in 888
the thing is when when you parse that in
JavaScript it gets converted to a number
so the 888 Ryan rounds to 900 for this
reason Twitter includes a secondary
field ID string which is which is a
string of the number and that doesn't
round but people run into this as a
problem all the time like it's kind of
easier to just use the ID rather than
the ID string and it's hard for Twitter
to remove it because of compatibility
sometimes the numbers don't overflow
like in that second line in this bug but
other times they do and you just are
referring to the wrong object another
case this comes up is in ID no numbers
so in file systems each file is
generally associated with with a number
which is sort of like a pointer to the
file and nodejs includes an API called
stat to read the I know number of a file
on Linux I know numbers are often kind
of low but on Windows they can sometimes
be really high and run into the same
kind of rounding issue
so this LSAT sync there's actually a
reproducible test case where you can
create a folder and create a couple
files in that folder which have I know
numbers which one of them ending in 27
but then it rounds up to 28 and another
file in the same folder has an item
number in 29 but then it rounds down to
the same 28 so if you try to pass those
I know numbers back to the system again
a
just not gonna work it's just the wrong
number to get around these kinds of
problems developers have created
libraries like bien jeaious which has
millions of downloads every week and
gives you an object API for this where
you can instantiate a new new big numb
and call methods on it to add or things
like that but there are some limitations
here because it's not as integrated into
the system so if you have something else
in the in the standard library or in the
web platform or node it's not it's not
obvious how to how to integrate with
this it's not as optimizable because the
JavaScript kit doesn't know about it so
the JavaScript engine can't use
knowledge of mathematics to make it
faster and it's also just an extra thing
to download and integrate which is
difficult in in some projects so what if
we had this in JavaScript itself going
back to the original example where we
add one and we get you know the same
number back again what if we could
indicate that we want to refer just two
integers using a suffix like n so 2 n to
the 53 n would be the same number
starting with a nine-inning with it too
but when you add 1 into it you'd get a 3
at the end and in here so the 2 goes to
3 and here stands for big int what is
this javascript it is soon begin to set
stage 3 in tc39 and we're adding it to
the javascript programming language
actually shipping in chrome now as of a
few days ago begins and shipping in
chrome 67 and in node master begins is
also supported begins being developed in
Firefox and Safari as well and it's on
the roadmap for edge but who's this tc39
and what are they what are they doing to
my java scripts so remember remember es6
es6 gave you nice features like
destructuring so if you have two
variables x and y you can swap them by
putting an array on the left hand side
and just swapping them
and so this and other things like
async/await we're all added by tc39 tc39
is a is a standards committee that's
part of Eknath and Akuma is this
this is standards body based in Geneva
sort of for administrative support but
then we in the committee are JavaScript
developers implementers you know people
who are making JavaScript work in web
browsers and node and Babel framework
authors like angular and ember and and
react and and and academics who have a
background in programming language
theory and more and we all get together
to produce this document the Ekman
script language specification if you
were going to print this out it would be
1200 pages it would be or more than 1200
pages I recommend just looking at the
website has these nice searching
features we developed this document on
on github it's an open source project
like any other with issues and pull
requests and we also we also develop it
at meetings so here there's a part of an
agenda for the meetings we always seem
to run over a little bit on the agenda
but we we meet every two months for
three days and we talk about the the
activity on github we also talk about
new proposals for extending the language
and these proposals move through stages
so if it if it's a big proposal like
like big in we don't just have a pull
request against the main spec and start
with that we instead make a separate
proposal that goes through these stages
we might have heard of stage one is just
a just a general idea we're discussing
sort of a problem space within the
committee stage two means that we have
an agreed on first draft that tc39 has
decided we're going to do something here
and
it's going to look more or less like
this by stage three all the details are
worked out and we have a complete first
specification and it's ready to go off
to implementers and by Stage four we
have multiple implementations and lots
of feedback from real usage and so we're
ready to just make it part of the actual
JavaScript standard so how did how did
begin go through this process actually
begins and or in 64 has been in
development for longer than the stage
process and longer than chrome and node
back in 1999 just a few years after
JavaScript was created long and you long
types were proposed and so these would
hold signed or unsigned 64-bit integers
but they they never quite made it in so
in es3 that that update was mostly
expansions to the library like regular
expressions es 4 was this huge project
that also was thinking of adding these
types but it got so complicated it just
had to be abandoned and in es5 to sort
of recover from that to heal from that
process the the language changes were
really minimal and included things like
cleaning up the object model and eval
and a few other library additions then
es6 made it made a whole bunch of
changes such as the this.d structuring
assignment that I just mentioned as part
of es6 the committee was talking about
adding value types which would have been
user defined user defined data types so
user defined primitives you can already
define your own objects but there's no
way to define your own thing like number
as a JavaScript programmer and you know
and we're still talking about doing
value types but they weren't added in in
es6 they're deferred until later so a
long long history of not not yet doing
larger integers but then recently in
November 2016 Brendan Eich proposed
again to the committee that we do in 64
rather than coupling it to the whole
value
package in 64 and unsigned in 64 was
proposed as a standalone proposal to
just add this one new new primitive type
by the by the following January we
settled on actually we want to do this
as bigint rather than 1864 I'll talk
about the reasons more in a bit
and then by that by that July we got to
stage three in the process and now it's
now chipping in from 67 so let's let's
go over how this went in more detail so
first each one the big thing you need
for stage 1 is to have a description of
the problem and the the motivation so
what what we did in tc39 was create this
proposal repository just a github
repository proposal bigint and made a
readme file that has some code samples
for how it might look has some
motivating use cases and some ideas for
what the semantics would look like we
also opened a bug tracker in the same
repository and invited various community
members to participate and give give
opinions about various different
semantic points so a couple of the big
discussions that we went through were
bigint verses in 64 so I mentioned in
the history that much of the time we've
been discussing adding 64-bit integers
to the language rather than adding
arbitrary sized integers and some of the
reasons for that were some people felt
like it would be a more minimal addition
so if you have a 64-bit integer then it
will just overflow or throw an exception
when you when you get out of bounds that
that could work for a lot of the
applications it works the whole point of
the proposal is to avoid the overflow
but you know sometimes 64 bits is enough
and people thought that this would be
maybe easier to convince browsers to
implement or it might execute faster but
when we talked more with the with the
browsers actually Benedict tomorrow from
from the v8 team sort of led this effort
to reconsider our query size integers
this way you never have to worry about
overflow
and it actually turns out that the way
that modern JavaScript engines work you
they have machinery for doing all this
sort of optimization for working with
numbers and particular ranges to convert
them to two integers and and at the same
time in 64 wouldn't be that fast without
all sorts of optimizations because it
has to be allocated in in the heap you
have to do all sorts of type checking
and to get it to the point where it's
actually sort of allocated in registers
or on this stack there's already there's
already a lot of magic going on and when
that same magic is applied it would work
for begin so we decided to you know bite
the bullet solve the whole problem
better and go with begin rather than in
64
the other big semantic point that we
discussed was what to do with mixed
types so in a language like Python you
can just add you know you can just add a
large integer and a float and you get a
float back and what we decided for
javascript is we don't actually want to
do that what we're doing instead is I
mean the whole point of begin is to be
this new data type that provides this
mathematical accuracy you don't have to
think about all the complexity of I
Triple E 754 you can just think about
you can just think about integers but
what integer would you get when you add
a very large integer to to the 53 plus
1.5 the answer isn't actually contained
in the set of integers or in the set of
representable floating point values so
what we decided is rather than come up
with the wrong answer when the whole
point of the feature is to come to the
right answer we would throw a type error
in this case and we would just say you
know we're not going to come to an
answer so actually you can't mix begins
and numbers in general in mathematical
operations
and this leads to to a best practice
that I'd recommend bigint SAR good when
you have a value that ranges that might
be larger than what can be represented
in numbers but if numbers are working
for you stick with them numbers still
work just fine for for small integers
and in general because we have to make
this decision up front it's because of
that that issue I just described you
know numbers numbers in use for what
they're in use for right now just still
works very well so to get to stage 2
from there to get to stage to the
committee wrote this this draft
specification document and this is just
like the the main document for the whole
specification except that it's only the
segment that that relates to this new
feature so it includes sort of some
insertions and some deletions and some
some new sections but you can ultimately
read it in the same HTML file and that's
generated from this specification format
this was created by by Brian Charlson
and Ron Buckton this X markup tool that
lets you use a combination of markdown
and grammar syntax to easily generate
these specification drafts my coworker
Robin Templeton Eddy galley also started
around this time implementing bigint in
spider monkey which is currently you
know starting to land so even though
stage 3 is when something is really
really ready for implementation and
really stable it's never too early to
get started prototyping and this process
leads to helps the development to the
future to get to stage 3 we needed to
sign off on this specification so in
particular a couple of committee members
or sometimes more than a couple of
committee members volunteer to read the
whole specification in a lot of detail
as well as the editors and see whether
it's ready so this this leads to a lot
of
you know typos being fixed and cases
being looked at closely and once we got
to this level of stability where the
committee signed off and the committee
is really saying yes we want to do this
feature Stage two is yes we want to do
this feature and stage three is we want
to do it this way and we really need
implementation feedback so this level of
stability led the v8 team to implement
big int and following that the the so
you know thank you Yakko kumara for for
great work leading the begin to
implementation and also coyote Mott
works on begin in JSC which is in
progress even once we got to stage three
even once we said that we had this level
of stability there were still some edge
cases that people came across that
because the feature hasn't shipped to
the web yet we were open to to
revisiting so there there were there
were tons of different edge cases like
this that we spent committee time on
before getting to stage three and then
even after stage three we looked at this
one so you know double equals and and
less than in JavaScript you can use them
to compare a number and a string and
when you do that it converts the string
to a number and it compares them as
numeric values so you know this is part
of JavaScript being maybe weakly typed
and having all these tasks everywhere
and so to make sure that big int is
consistent with to make sure that big
int is consistent with numbers we did
that same behavior in in in bigan but we
accidentally in this second case here
we're converting the big int to number
and it would compare as less than when
it's actually the same value because
that number would be rounding down to
get to stage for what we're going to
need is full test 262 tests there's a
conformance test suite that that
verifies that
that implementations are working right
so we have those conformance tests a
pull request to the main specification
to pull this in well there's still a
little bit more refactoring to do for
that and in two implementations where we
have one full implementation but the
next two are still in progress so maybe
we'll get this by es 2019 we'll see
or maybe ES 2020 hope so so to let you
know how to get involved there's there's
just a lot of different ways to get
involved here feedback on github issues
is really great I'd love to hear about
whether a feature proposal works for you
if there are pieces missing or if the
case should be handled differently and
this was really useful for working
through tons of issues with begins tests
262 tests there's this project to
implement tests for the JavaScript
language itself and it's an open source
project that's happening happy to have
new contributions what we find is that
when something is missing from the test
suite actually different browsers or
different JavaScript implementations
have different behavior
because different people end up reading
the same specification differently by
accident and so it's it's really
important to have a full test suite
there's other parts other standards have
other tests like web platform tests and
we have test 262 and so for example
here's a pull request to add tests that
check that adding a number and a bigint
throws a type error and in for the big
int project tests to see to help make
implementations correct the first time
and stay correct sometimes you know Maya
from the v8 team made a joke to me
sometimes implementations make so many
optimizations that they optimize away
the specification itself and so this
helps prevent that you know even as
you're maintaining the project then you
still have all these very complete
correctness tests but it went even
further than that because the people
working on these tests took a really
close look at all the edge cases and
helped work through a lot of the design
decisions
and then more than six test engineers
collaborated especially engineers from
from Baku and agalya we're also happy to
have help on documentation and education
so with this readme file number of
people contributed and it's really
important to understand the different
mental models that JavaScript
programmers have some you're not people
aren't programming thinking through the
entire specification and and different
people have different mental models so
this this is especially useful we try to
compare a bunch of different ways of
thinking through code when designing
language features so for example in the
bigint design process ashley williams
pointed out that when learning when
learning programming a lot of
programmers have an intuition that
variables should have particular types
so this made us feel not quite as bad
about not permitting mixed operations
between big int and number because this
is this is actually a pretty intuitive
thing for people to learn that you know
a value has a particular type it would
it's also welcome to to implement things
so you can contribute to any sort of you
know lots of different implementations
of javascript and through
implementations it's not just about
getting javascript to developers but
every single all these three
implementations have began that are in
progress or complete contributed to the
to the design of the feature it's also
possible to you know if you're not able
to do this development yourself
companies like Bloomberg and Google a
sponsor sponsor work to to push these
things forward and of course in these
meetings were open to new members so you
know let me know if you want to get
involved as a as a DC there nine
delegate it's an organizational
membership so something like your
employer would join and or there are
also nonprofit memberships so as
takeaway please if you're if you're
interested in in building the future of
JavaScript get involved in tc39 you can
go to our website and
you know now you have begins and use use
begins for integers which may be very
big and use numbers for numbers that are
smaller so I'm little then and you know
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]